-
IT'S NOT IN THE --
IT'S NOT A FORMAL CHARGE, BUT
THAT IS STRONG LANGUAGE, QUITE
SIGNIFICANT.
>> ATTORNEY GEORGE CONWAY, WHY
WOULD TEAM TRUMP WANT THIS
INFORMATION OUT THERE?
WHY WOULD THEY EVEN ASK FOR A
SPECIAL MASTER, KNOWING WHAT
THE EVIDENCE IS?
>> IT'S INSANE.
THEY ASKED FOR, BASICALLY THEY
ASKED FOR THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT PUNCH THEM IN THE
FACE.
AND THAT IS WHAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT DID IN THIS BRIEF.
AS ELLIOTT POINTS OUT, THEY
TALK ABOUT OBSTRUCTION.
THESE DOCUMENTS WERE MOVED
AROUND, FROM ROOM TO ROOM.
AND THEY FOCUS, THEY ACTUALLY
SHOW US THE CERTIFICATION.
I DON'T THINK WE'VE SEEN IT
BEFORE, THE CERTIFICATION FOR
TRUMP'S LAWYERS THAT SAID, HEY,
THERE WERE NO MORE DOCUMENTS,
NO MORE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
LEFT HERE, IN RESPONSE TO A
SUBPOENA.
THEY GAVE A RED WALL OF
DOCUMENTS BACK, AND IT TURNED
OUT, IN A CERTIFIED, THEN
THAT'S IT, THAT'S ALL THE
RESPONSE OF DOCUMENTS THAT WE
HAVE.
AND IT TURNED OUT THERE WERE NO
DOCUMENTS ANYWHERE OTHER THAN
IN THAT STORAGE ROOM.
TURNS OUT THERE'S DOCUMENTS IN
HIS OFFICE, THERE ARE DOCUMENTS
ALL OVER THE PLACE.
AND TONS OF THEM, I MEAN, THEY
HAVE --
THIS FACTUAL RECITATION HAS HIM
DEAD TO RIGHTS.
THERE IS NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
AND IT EXPLAINS A LOT TODAY
ABOUT WHAT WE WERE SEEING
DONALD TRUMP, TRUE THING O